I saw you just the other day just a
couple days ago and we had some food and
then I'm walking back and I saw you
getting to the sweetest ride you got
into a beautiful sports car yeah that
thing looked fast it's very fast
it's electric no it's uh I Drive a
German car a Porsche yeah it was a dream
come true to get it and because I when I
watch police chases I'm like someday and
I will be prepared
no I yeah I like to drive very fast
here's the thing that's how do you drive
fast in this time I mean there's you
know it's it's not like we're in Nevada
where the speed limits like 190 you know
you you you got a you got to keep it
slow don't you you'd be surprised on
there's a couple places you can open it
up and if you are you almost will hit it
or two but but I haven't got any tickets
in this car yet so I'm very pleased
about do you have if you get pulled over
do you ever try and play the celebrity
card yes well that's all the time we
have no I go I am Annie Richter please
let me know i yeah I the kid this is it
takes about 12 minutes to tell it so no
uh there was a I played football in
college not well it was bad I was
terrible I was on the University of
Washington Huskies I made a lot of guys
look really good when they tackled me
and they gave me a ring for it
and it was a Rose Bowl ring and I got
pulled over and the cops saw me wearing
the ring and he was like sir go ahead
and I was like yes oh so he was a
Huskies fan or a football fan yeah yeah
and so he let me go but then so then I
kept the ring in my glove compartment
and so when I get pulled over I would be
like hello officer
[Laughter]
that it would reflect into his face and
you'd be like God you've just doubled
the fine yeah so that doesn't work
do you ever some people try sob stories
people try to get sympathy by telling
talking about something unfortunate in
their lives yeah I
usually well I did get my dad out of a
ticket when I was a kid
State Patrol pulled him over and I began
sobbing I'm a whole family's in the car
and I can't and I was like 25 so I 25 I
was on the way back of the car and I
just start ball I was like don't shoot
my dad my dad and the officer was
totally flushed he was like legs look I
tell your son I'm not gonna shoot you
and just drive slower and so then my dad
was like I hope you can do that again
there's gotta be an age limit on it at
some point I think when you're in your
late 40s you'd be surprised how often
that is yeah yeah we're either late
forties like I know I or you good topic
like I know I murdered that guy I'm so
sorry I does that give me other ticket
that's you a different ticket you're you
are IIIi can relate to you because I am
a silly dad our kids are similar ages
you're a very silly dad and I know that
both of our kids were obsessed with
Legos yes and the Lego people I believe
they are geniuses because they'll keep
coming up with new ways to get kids
hooked on more Legos yeah my I there's a
cartoon called lego ninjago
have you heard of it oh yes parents you
have it's ingenious because Lego for a
while they've make Star Wars Lego see
the movie by the Lego but then in Lego
said screw that let's just make a
cartoon where Legos are the cartoons and
at the end we'll just sew all the new
sets that we made in the cartoon and
then the parents will have to buy them
yeah cut out they used to have to like
pay a piece to Lucas or whatever now
they're like we're gonna make our own
movies starring Legos it's ingenious and
so my kid yeah they were like dad
there's a snake car now take us to the
Lego store now and I'll be like I'll
Drive us there right now and then then I
would say like we can't the cars broke
and we have to take the uniforms
in the corner have to take the unicorns
in lego store and that's where my kid
will go dad
are you being sarcastic and that really
happened and then sarcastic and then
I'll be like no I'm not being sarcastic
and then he'll go are you being
sarcastic again my kid go that he
measures my jokes he'll be like all
right dad no jokes for a week once in a
while I get no jokes for a year daddy a
year a year yeah I'd be fine with that